The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: That
is the point here.
This is not a heavy math
derivation kind of thing.
This is not-- we
are not going to go
into great mathematical
detail in quantum mechanics.
Now, we will show
some equations,
we'll work with
equations, because I
want you to know what they are.
You got to know
what's under the hood.
But we're not going to go
into sort of gory detail
in solving complex
quantum problems on paper.
That's where the tools help
lift you away from that.
And it also is kind of the
flavor of this class, which
is that this is about practice.
This is about learning
the basic concepts,
and then applying them to
real problems and materials.
And my enjoyment is in
energy, so the problems
we'll do in this part are going
to be energy-related problems.
How many of you have
had quantum mechanics?
I wouldn't have
expected that many.
How many of you have never seen
quantum mechanics in any form?
Raise your hands,
because it's good.
It's good.
We're going to start-- we're
going to do quantum mechanics--
we're going to do a couple
lectures here-- oh, this
is what we're going to do.
That's our outline for the
class, for the second half.
And you can see that
what we're going to do
is we're going to
kind of gently learn
the key aspects of
quantum mechanics
that I'd like you to
know for the modeling
that we're going
to do of materials.
And then we're going
to actually apply it.
We're going to stop right
here in the derivations,
in the theory, and
then we're going
to start applying that
to real energy problems.
So then we're going
to do two lectures
on how to apply what we just
learned to two different energy
topics.
One, solar thermal fuels.
Very cool and exciting material.
And another, hydrogen storage.
Also very cool and exciting.
Then we're going to turn to
how you go from modeling atoms
to modeling solids
with quantum mechanics,
where different things happen.
How many of you have
heard of a band structure?
Yeah.
Now, how many of you can tell
me, from the band structure,
why silicon solar cells
are too expensive?
Now, you will be able to
tell me that right here.
We're going to know.
And that's a really
exciting thing,
because it's all in
the band structure.
That answer is all in
So many properties of materials
come out of these basic quantum
mechanical property
maps that you get.
So that's what we're
going to do here.
And then we'll go more
general and do applications
in nanotechnology
and more broadly.
How many of you have heard
of quantum confinement?
That's down here.
Do you know what it is?
Somebody tell me what it is.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is it?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
yeah, let's hear it.
AUDIENCE: So what is it?
So you have the [? key, ?]
[? and that ?] [? holds ?]
electrons, stuff like that,
and they both [INAUDIBLE] take
a small section, it's so
small that it emits different
colors--
I mean, I don't know.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
Now, but why?
You have electrons and holes,
which are just positive
and negative charges, right?
You talked about that.
And then you make it small,
and it emits a different color
light.
What emits a
different color light?
AUDIENCE: Quantum dot.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Quantum dot, for example.
Now, why?
Can anybody tell me why?
AUDIENCE: The [? sides ?] all
emit from a certain wavelength?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Why?
Changes the fundamental gap
of the material, but why?
It's something called
quantum confinement.
Actually, it's nothing more
than what those two words say.
Quantum confinement is the
squeezing of quantum things.
And in this case,
our quantum things
are positive and
negative charges.
Right?
And it turns out, when
you make an expectation,
the positive and negative
charge like to be
kind of close to each other.
They don't like to
go away, necessarily.
Sometimes they
like to stay close.
But they don't like
to get too close.
So if you make the material
smaller than the closeness
they like to get,
then they're squeezed.
They're confined.
And when you confine
quantum things,
you get interesting effects.
That's why I can take something
that, say, ordinarily looks
like this, and take
a small piece of it,
and all of a sudden,
it turns blue.
Like, how cool is that?
You changed the color
just by changing the size.
That's quantum confinement.
That's something
that has everything
to do with quantum mechanics.
Right?
Electrons and holes, positive
and negative charges.
You're not going to get that--
you're not getting
that over here.
Mm-mm.
That's part one.
Now we're going to go
to quantum mechanics.
Because you can't simulate
electrons and holes
in part one, but now you can.
Well, you will be able to.
And we're going to
actually-- you're
going to be able to tell me
what color a quantum dot could
be just by solving these
equations on a computer.
Because now we're going to
capture quantum mechanics
and apply it to things
like nanotechnology.
OK, so that's just
kind of a flavor
of where we're going to go.
Any questions?
Mm-hmm.
It's a quantum world.
That's where we're
going to start.
And the reason I put this is
because you can do Shakespeare
very quickly.
There are people who have
been doing it for a long time.
"Reducing expectations
for over 20 years."
I just like that quote.
There is something called the
Reduced Shakespeare Company.
And that's what I'm
going to try to do today.
We're going to go through the
basics of quantum mechanics
in one lecture that's
not really meant
to teach you too much
about quantum mechanics,
or go too much into depth.
Again, I want to go through
some of the key aspects,
but really to get
a sense for it,
not to go into great
mathematical depth.
That's what you take
a quantum course for.
OK?
But I need you to
understand some
of the key aspects of
quantum before we embark
on modeling quantum mechanics.
And so I want to start
with why, and why did we
even need this theory?
And so we'll talk a
little bit about that.
And then we'll talk about
some of the key aspects, which
is this wave-particle duality.
And then this is it right here.
That's the equation
we're going to be
solving for all of part two.
The Schrodinger equation.
Has anybody seen the
Schrodinger equation?
Yeah, a little bit.
Have any of you solved it
for [? A? ?] I saw a so-so.
A little kind of like
you sort of solved it?
What happened there?
AUDIENCE: I solved it,
but probably incorrectly.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
OK, I'll take that.
That's good.
And what else-- what other
problems have you solved
with the Schrodinger equation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hydrogen atom?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Hydrogen atom, OK.
That's where we'll end today.
But still listen, because it's
going to be really interesting.
Any other-- who else has solved
the Schrodinger equation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Particle in a box.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Particle in the box.
AUDIENCE: Periodic potential?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Periodic potential.
Any others?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Quantum tunneling.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Quantum tunneling, cool.
Anyone else solve it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That's what we're
going to do at the very end.
That's the hydrogen atom.
It's a harmonic potential.
Somebody said something else?
That's not quite a
harmonic potential, but.
AUDIENCE: Cat in the box.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Any
other-- cat in the box!
I've got a cat in the
box today for you!
I put a cat in a box.
The thing is, what's interesting
about all those examples
you all just said?
AUDIENCE: They're
all [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
They're all kind of what?
AUDIENCE: Simple.
AUDIENCE: Exactly solvable.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Exactly
solvable and simple,
and therefore?
To someone in course three?
AUDIENCE: Boring.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Eh.
Right?
That's where we
have changed so much
in what we can do
because of computation.
So now, because of
the approximations
that you're going to learn in
the next couple of lectures,
and the speed of
computers, we can actually
solve the Schrodinger equation
for realistic materials.
That's why we can
have this class.
We would not be
having this class--
no.
We wouldn't be having part
two of this class back
in the 1970s, 1980s.
Oh, that reminds me.
You should go to Berni Alder.
Are all of you aware
of Berni Alder's talk?
He is really one of
the key foundations
of computational science in
this country and in the world.
And he contributed to
some of the very first
molecular dynamic
simulations ever done.
And really helped-- and
that was in the 1950s.
So he's going to be a speaker.
Who can tell me when?
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Tomorrow at 4:00.
Where?
Somewhere on this campus, Berni
Alder will be speaking at 4:00.
Please find him
and go if you can.
He just really made some really
important key contributions
to this field and
helped to launch it.
It gave credibility.
He saw-- in molecular dynamics
simulations in the 1950s,
he could see really interesting
phenomena-- phase transitions
happening in materials.
Really helped to launch
the field of computation
in materials.
OK, so let's go.
So here, you've seen this
picture in the first part.
And you've also seen this.
And, see, this is what?
In part one, this is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Force field, Lennard-Jones.
And where do you get that?
Because you need it, right?
Can you do part
one without that?
Now, so where do you get it?
AUDIENCE: Quantum [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, you could.
Or you could get it from where?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Experiment.
But see, if I'm making new
materials that have never
been made, or if I'm making
materials where interactions
are happening that I can't
really measure, because they're
really hard to measure, then
where could you get something
like this?
You can't do the experiment.
That's where we can go
all the way down to here.
And that's another place
where this whole realm
of quantum modeling is
going to be important.
So that's where we are,
the bottom of the barrel.
But not any less important.
This is just-- this has nothing
to do with quantum mechanics
at all, but I thought
it was pretty cool.
Right?
This is just a
guy who has this--
he's got a camera
pointing that way,
and then he's got a little
projector and a very
specialized material
here, and he's
projecting the image
onto his jacket,
and so it looks like
he's transparent.
But the point being that I
thought it was a cool idea,
I guess.
Sort of interesting.
So you can see, the
car's sort of there,
but I don't think the
car's really there.
Anyway, he needs to focus it.
But weird things happen
in quantum mechanics.
Really, really weird things.
And it is a very quantum world.
If we understand those basic
particles like electrons,
then we can almost
understand everything.
Almost everything.
Seriously.
OK?
So if you want to
know the properties,
like mechanical
properties, and you
have a good potential
of this piece of iron,
for this piece of iron, you
can do classical mechanics.
But if you want to understand
the mechanical properties,
and you don't have
a good potential,
well, you may need
quantum mechanics.
And certainly, if you
want to understand
the electrical properties,
or the optical properties,
can you do that with
classical potentials?
Tell me why.
Why I can't get
electrical properties
with classical potentials?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because you're
modeling the entire atoms.
You're just basically
considering the nucleus
and not really talking
about the electrons.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Exactly.
And what do I need for
electrical properties?
You got to know
about the electrons.
Band structures!
Band structures
will tell us about
the electrical properties.
You will learn to see--
it's like The Matrix.
You will learn to read band
structures as whole cities
to explore that tell
you all about things
like this, and this.
It's really powerful.
And it tells you--
and so all we need
to do is go down one
more scale, because this
is where you've been, and
this is where we're going.
We're going here.
Do electrons actually orbit?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
What do they do?
AUDIENCE: Go around [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
They go around?
AUDIENCE: No, they fly around.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
They fly around?
Sounds better.
What?
AUDIENCE: They
have their orbitals
that they can-- that there's
a possibility that they'll
[? be at. ?]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
That's where we're going.
Why do we call them orbitals?
We'll get to that.
Here's another motivation.
And this is a great example
of what I was just talking
about in that potential.
If I have the right potential,
and I do my classical force
field calculations, I
can feel pretty golden
about simulating the behavior of
materials, like how it cracks.
Did you guys do
crack propagation?
Ol' Professor Buehler
likes crack propagation.
There are not many
people on the planet
who more about crack propagation
than Professor Buehler.
But look at this.
I've cracked this piece
of-- what is this?
Graphene, let's say.
Silicon?
AUDIENCE: Silicon.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Oh, it's silicon.
This is silicon just
looked at from the side.
Yep, there they are, two.
I've cracked this
piece of silicon.
I guess I could have read
"silicon" there and known.
And I can't measure
it experimentally.
And so I crack it in the
computer with something called
an EDIP potential that was
fit to certain experimental
parameters, and then I
crack it in a computer
with a tight-binding model,
and look at the difference.
Is that the same crack?
Is that the same property?
Is it happening in the same way?
Absolutely not.
It's completely different.
Qualitatively, quantitatively,
the results you'll get
and the findings you publish
will be totally different,
depending on which
potential you choose.
So that's really--
this is the reason why
we need these more
accurate-- a way, at least,
to get more accurate potentials.
And then you can get these
other properties, as I said.
So you can get things like
where the electrons are.
You can model things like
Raman spectra, which have
to do with electrons and light.
You can model things
like reactions.
Now, sometimes potentials--
like especially reacs.
Did you run reacs potentials?
Reacs-- the name "reacs"
makes me think reaction.
Does it make you think that?
So they're actually
modeled for reactions.
And that means that
they can break bonds.
However, there are
plenty of reactions--
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZES]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: --salute--
where reacs can actually not
get the right physics, the right
structure of the potential.
Why?
Well, take a look at this one.
This is butadiene plus
ethylene going to cyclohexane--
hexene.
It's one of the simplest ways
you can actually make a ring.
Watch those electrons.
Those are the electrons of
the part of the system that's
doing the reaction.
That's where the electrons are.
And where those electrons are
is what determines everything
about the reaction-- the
barrier, whether it happens.
And let's see if I
can get it to play.
And now, watch them.
Watch them.
It's like balloon animals.
See, they pop up on the top,
and then they flow across.
And then they do
a big shape-shift
as the reaction
actually happens,
and they curve back around,
and they bubble up on top.
And that's the final position
probability of those electrons.
It's a very simple
reaction, but the behavior
is extremely complex.
So when you fit a potential,
this is what you're ignoring.
All of that complexity.
And you're trying to fit
it to some functional form,
and reacs has a whole lot
of degrees of freedom,
so it actually can fit some
of this complexity very well.
But that just gives you a
sense of the kind of thing
that's happening, and why you
can miss important aspects
with potentials.
So in the Standard
Model, atoms are
made by these massive
point-like nuclei.
That's what you've been doing.
And now they're going to be
surrounded by these electrons.
And you're going to
have core electrons,
and then you're going to have
the valence electrons, which
do all the work.
They're the ones that
bind together and do
all the interesting stuff.
Somebody tell me, who
knows about the chemistry,
like s, p, d filling?
Good.
Somebody tell me, how many
electrons are there in carbon?
AUDIENCE: Six.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Six.
And how many are core
and how many are valence?
What's what there?
AUDIENCE: Two core, two
[? valence-- ?] four core,
two valence.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK,
so it goes 1s, 2s.
That's four.
2p, how many are in the 2p?
Four, two?
How many?
Two?
Like that, that's good.
Now, what about silicon?
Which number is that?
Oh.
We really like materials--
material scientists
really like silicon.
It's good material.
14.
How many electrons
are in the valence?
Yeah, it's the same--
because in carbon--
you see, you had
the 2s and the 2p,
four electrons in the valence.
And in silicon, you've
got the 3s and the 3p,
four electrons in the valence.
Right?
But you see, here's carbon.
And here's 2p.
And now here's silicon.
This is 1s, 2s, 2p.
Is this making sense to people?
How many of you
have not seen this?
It's OK.
We'll talk a little
bit about this.
So these are filled, filled,
and so on, up to here.
And then you got these guys.
And this is the valence,
and this is the valence.
Those are the electrons that
do all of the interacting.
Those are the ones that
do the chemical bonding.
They're the ones
that we're going
to care about in this class.
We are not going to be working
with these core electrons.
Those are core electrons.
So we're going to
freeze those out,
because they don't really
play much of a role
in the kinds of properties we're
going to actually care about
in this class, OK?
And I won't talk much
about how we do that.
We do that with something called
pseudo potentials, which model
the core part of the electron.
So this part, we're
going to get rid of.
Now, somebody tell
me why, in looking
at this, why we are made out
of carbon and not silicon?
The valence electrons look
pretty similar, don't they?
You got a couple of s and
a couple of p in each case.
OK, higher.
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: More
metallic [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: More metallic?
Maybe.
[? Except so, ?]
because I'm metallic.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What was that?
AUDIENCE: More reactive?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: More active?
Mm, not sure about that.
You could argue that if you
think about the alkalis,
if you're thinking in
that way, that it wants
to lose these electrons more.
Carbon can be a
very reactive atom.
Actually, the bond in diamond
is considerably higher energy
than the bond in silicon.
So why are we made out of
carbon and not silicon?
We'll come back to that.
Think about it.
It's cheaper?
It's cost-efficient.
Actually, nature is always
really good about that.
Not quite the answer.
It's real.
These electrons that we're going
to be simulating, they exist!
They can be seen, and look
at that complex structure!
That's the complexity of a
bond measured in experiment.
That's a real experimental bond.
And it shows where
that electron density
is in the bond, and look
at how complicated that is.
And that's what
I'm talking about.
And we can calculate
that-- well, this
is a different material,
but you can see
a similar sort of complexity.
We can calculate that complexity
with quantum mechanics.
And you can see again
by looking at this--
look at this.
I mean, there's like a
ball underneath a donut
and a teardrop, and
a donut and a ball.
Did your classical
potential get all of that?
No way.
It's just averaging
over this, right?
And so once we go to trying
to calculate properties
of materials that are
this complex, electrons,
we really got to get it right.
And that's what the
Schrodinger equation will do.
So now, why is this important
to solve in the computer?
Well, it's sort of
the same reasons for--
these are the same
reasons for classical,
the first part of the class.
It provides us with a
microscopic understanding.
It has predictive power.
And in this case, we can really
say it's first-principles.
And you hear this word
"first-principles--"
how many of you have
had "first-principles?"
What does it mean?
Take a guess.
AUDIENCE: From the basic--
just from basic axiom.
You're not really
assuming very much.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Exactly.
And in this case, what
are we going to assume?
What is the only input
into the simulation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well,
what's the only input
into the simulation
of that equation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: The atom what?
AUDIENCE: Like the
atom that you're--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Yeah, which is what?
Just the atom.
The atom number.
And maybe its position.
That's important.
Like where the atom is.
And the charge.
The charge on the atom.
Is it ionized, is it not.
And that's it.
Not really, ha, because we
have to make approximations.
But ideally, that's all
we would need to put in
to solve first-principles.
That is, to solve without
any other fits or inputs.
Just the atom, which atom
is it, and where is it
is what you put in.
And the challenges
we have is that this
is a much more
computationally-intensive kind
of simulation.
So how long-- who was
saying that it was too long?
And then we'll have classical--
yeah, how long was it taken?
AUDIENCE: Six hours.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Six
hours, and how many atoms?
AUDIENCE: One--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: One atom?
AUDIENCE: No, 150,000.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Oh, 150,000.
OK, good.
So if we tried to simulate
150,000 atoms, that's not even
a sentence I can start.
Actually, in quantum
mechanics, you
can't even get close to that.
So if you try to do 150
atoms in quantum mechanics,
it could easily
take you six hours,
and it could take
you even much more.
Our goal in the
homeworks will be
to make sure the simulations
take as long as possible.
I'm kidding.
But we'll make sure that
they don't take too long.
But they're slow and painful,
and you will feel that pain.
Not because we're
going to make problems
where you have to
simulate for a long time,
but because you'll just see.
You'll be like, wait a second,
I only got two atoms in here.
Why does this take an hour?
Well, it's because even
with all the approximations
and the computer
speed, it just takes
longer to do these
kinds of calculations
that are more complex.
OK?
How many people know where the
fastest computer in the world
is?
I asked this question already.
You know the answer.
Where is it?
AUDIENCE: Google.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Google.
How many people
know how many times
I've asked them for an account?
It's many.
They never gave it to me.
I would love to run
on Google's computer.
OK, classical mechanics
goes back a long way.
This is what you've
been solving.
You've been doing a
lot of F equals ma.
And there are problems with it
that led to quantum mechanics.
I'm just going to give
you a couple of examples
because they're
fun, and then I'm
going to show you a
really goofy movie.
Has anybody seen the
really goofy quantum movie
that I'm going to show?
AUDIENCE: Is it Dr. Quantum?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's not Dr.
Quantum, but that sounds cool.
Maybe it's Dr. Quan-- no, I
don't think it's Dr. Quantum.
Has anybody seen really
goofy quantum movies?
I love goofy movies.
If you had me for 3012, you
know I like strange movies.
It's a little thing.
And they're just a
couple, so I promise
you there won't be too many.
One I'll show you today, and
one I'll show you on Thursday.
Some of the problems
that led to the need
to develop a new theory
were the classical atom,
the quantization of properties,
the wave aspect of matter.
We'll talk about those.
And then black-body radiation,
which I won't talk about,
but that's a really cool
one because of the word they
use to describe the failure.
How many people know
what I'm talking about?
It's called the ultraviolet--
AUDIENCE: Catastrophe?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Catastrophe!
I love it.
You can't really call
theories today a catastrophe.
You got to have a lot of--
but that was a catastrophe.
That was really a catastrophe.
Because the energy
that was going
to be emitted from a black
body just kept going up and up
and up and up.
And it doesn't do
that in experiment.
That's a catastrophe.
Catastrophe, when you
use words like that,
you know you need a new theory.
A lot of really, really,
really smart people
were thinking about
these problems.
They were aware of them.
They knew they had these
problems back at the time.
And they were really
working intensely
on saying, well, why are we
having all these problems
describing the world?
We've been good to
go for 400 years.
And now this?
350 years.
What's going on?
In the classical atom, the
problem there is that, you see,
if you think about
a hydrogen atom
as a plus charge surrounded
by a negative charge-- that's
the nucleus, and
there's the proton,
and there's the electron.
And if it's orbiting, then
it has to be accelerating.
And we know that an
accelerating charge
is going to give off energy
in the form of radiation.
Right?
Well, if that were true--
and we know it is true.
In some situations, they
knew it very well to be true.
That's what a synchrotron is.
But then this should
just spiral, right?
And it should just collapse
into the center here.
Why doesn't it do that?
Do you know how long a
hydrogen atom should be stable,
according to that classical
world, that classical picture
of accelerating charge?
It's accelerating,
by the way, just
to stay on course
around this circle.
So it's giving off
radiation, losing energy,
meaning its orbit--
it should come closer
and closer to the center.
How long would that be stable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What fraction?
Give me a 10 to the
minus something.
AUDIENCE: 12.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
right around there.
10 to the minus 10,
10 to the minus 12.
That's how long hydrogen
atoms would be in existence
if classical physics described
them, which it doesn't.
And then there was this.
And this was a really
cool thing that
also could not be described
by the classical world.
And again, this is my reduced
Shakespeare version of quantum,
so we're covering these very
general, very interesting
topics just to give you
a flavor and a feeling.
And then, if you
want to learn more,
there's just so much you
can read about these.
They're really cool
experiments that were done.
This is the experiment that
won Einstein the Nobel Prize.
It's very important
work, but it's probably
one of his least
profound pieces of work.
But it was very
important, again,
to start to understand
this duality between waves
and particles, which I'll
talk about in a few minutes.
And what he found is that if
you take a piece of metal,
and you shine a light on it,
the energy from the light
can kick electrons out.
But what was thought
is that if you increase
the intensity of the
light, that you'd
increase how much energy these
particles get kicked out by.
You just increase the
intensity of the light,
and then you could get
these things to come out
at higher and higher energies.
But if you plot the energy
of an electron coming out
of the metal versus the
intensity of the light,
it's a flat line.
It does not depend on
the intensity of light.
You get more electrons
out, but you don't get
them to be any more energetic.
And that had to lead
to a picture of light
not necessarily being a wave.
Because instead,
what you find is
that there is this very
strong direct dependence
of the energy of the
electrons that come out
when you shine light
on a piece of metal,
and the frequency of the light.
And so what Einstein said
is, well, maybe light
can be thought of as particles
that have an energy that
depends on their frequency.
And he wrote this thing down.
So they have an
energy that depends
on this Planck's constant, this
thing here, this h, or h bar.
Do you like a bar, do you not?
Do you like pi?
Do you like 2 pi Do you
want to write that, not?
This is all-- it's a free world,
and you guys can write h or h
bar, however you want.
That's my feeling about it.
I'll stop there.
h bar.
h.
2 pi But you'll need to get
it right for solving problems,
right?
But this is the energy,
and it's quantized.
Well, no, sorry, it's
not quantized yet.
I didn't say that.
But it's a particle.
It's based on the frequency.
The energy goes as the
frequency of the light,
and that's what was measured.
Kind of building on the
understanding of what's
going on.
And this is a great one.
When you look out-- you
see, if you excite an atom,
if you excite the
electron in an atom,
and you let it go back down--
so if you excite an electron,
let's say of a hydrogen atom.
Here's your hydrogen
atom, and here's
that electron that's orbiting.
It's not orbiting, but we're
going to say it's orbiting.
And you excite it up in energy,
and then it goes back down,
it emits light.
And so you can look
out into the world--
which is whole lot of hydrogen--
and you can say, well, what
kind of light do I see?
And you would think, according
to classical physics,
the classical world
said, well, it
could be excited to any
amount from different reasons,
can excite an electron.
We won't talk about that now.
Instead, you look out, and you
see what wavelengths of light
are coming at you from
hydrogen and space,
and you don't see a
continuous spectrum at all.
You see only very, very
certain wavelengths.
So why?
How could that possibly be?
That was-- now we say, well,
it's just quantization.
Particle in a box, which
I'll get to in a second.
But back then, they didn't
have particle in a box.
They didn't have Schrodinger.
They didn't even really
know whether light was
a particle, a wave, or what.
They were really
grappling with that.
Now-- and it actually
is even more complex,
and we'll see this complexity
in the next couple lectures.
We'll be able to actually
calculate this if we want,
than just those
discrete energies.
There were these big
jumps, and then there
were these little jumps.
What's up with that?
They didn't just
see discrete things,
they saw them sort
of bundled up.
And then, if you
were lucky enough
to have looked at
one of these series,
and you were like, a-ha,
I got the green one,
then you got it to be
named after you, if it was
one of the first five or six.
And that's why they have names.
And then they stopped naming
them, because they were like,
well, OK, we kind
of get it already.
Like, I don't know if there's
a name for the sixth one.
Maybe there is.
Does anybody know?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: See, now,
I could take that as ageism,
but I won't.
Because, now-- I'm kidding.
My group makes fun
of my age very often.
Now, OK.
This is the time to
put down your PDAs--
if you're in the back
and looking at them--
and to pay attention, because
this is a really fun movie
and I wouldn't want you to
miss it just because you're
texting somebody.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- And here we are.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Is that quantum guy?
OK.
- Granddaddy of all
quantum weirdness--
the infamous double
slit experiment.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Got to
know about the double slit.
- To understand this
experiment, we first
need to see how particles, or
little balls of matter, act.
If we randomly shoot
a small object--
say, a marble--
at the screen, we
see a pattern on the
back wall where they
went through the slit and hit.
Now, if we add a
second slit, we would
expect to see a second band
duplicated to the right.
Now let's look at waves.
The waves hit the
slit and radiate out,
striking the back wall
with the most intensity
directly in line with the slit.
The line of brightness
on the back screen
shows that intensity.
This is similar to the
line the marbles make.
But when we add the second slit,
something different happens.
If the top of one wave meets
the bottom of another wave,
they cancel each other out.
So now there is an interference
pattern on the back wall.
Places where the two tops meet
are the highest intensity--
the bright lines-- and where
they cancel, there is nothing.
So when we throw things--
that is, matter-- through
two slits, we get this--
two bands of [? hits. ?]
And with waves,
we get an interference
pattern of many bands.
Good, so far.
Now let's go quantum.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Now that's
what I'm talking about.
- An electron is a tiny,
tiny bit of matter,
like a tiny marble.
Let's fire a stream
through one slit.
It behaves just
like the marble--
a single band.
So if we shoot these tiny
bits through two slits,
we should get, like
the marbles, two bands.
What?
An interference pattern!
We fired electrons, tiny
bits of matter through,
and we get a pattern like
waves, not like little marbles.
How?
How could pieces of matter
create an interference pattern
like a wave?
It doesn't make sense.
But physicists are clever.
They thought, maybe
those little balls
are bouncing off each other
and creating that pattern.
So they decide to shoot
electrons through one
at a time.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: This is cool.
- There is no way they can
interfere with each other.
But after an hour of this,
the same interference pattern
is seen to emerge.
The conclusion is inescapable.
The single electron
leaves as a particle,
becomes a wave of potentials,
goes through both slits,
and interferes with itself to
hit the wall like a particle.
But mathematically,
it's even stranger.
It goes through both slits,
and it goes through neither,
and it goes through
just one, and it
goes through just the other.
All of these possibilities
are in superposition
with each other.
But physicists were
completely baffled by this,
so they decided to
peek and see which
slit it actually goes through.
And they put a measuring
device by one slit
to see which one it went
through and let it fly.
But the quantum world
is far more mysterious
than they could have imagined.
When they observed,
the electron went back
to behaving like
a little marble!
It produced a pattern of two
bands, not an interference
pattern of many.
The very act of
measuring, or observing,
which slit it went
through meant it only
went through one, not both.
The electron decided
to act differently,
as though it was aware
it was being watched.
And it was here that
physicists stepped forever
into the strange neverworld
of quantum events.
What is matter--
marbles or waves?
And waves of what?
And what does an observer
have to do with any of this?
The observer collapsed the wave
function simply by observing.
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Nice.
That's pretty cool.
I mean, it's a little bit--
but does that blow you away?
Seriously?
I mean, I-- so here's the thing.
I strongly recommend
you take this movie
out the next time
you go to a bar,
and when you're at the
table, maybe you're
on your second round--
wait, I keep doing this.
You guys shouldn't be drinking.
Sorry.
I keep making this mistake.
OK, you're drinking
tomato juice,
and you bust out
this movie, you're
going to blow people away.
And it's a really great--
it's a conversation starter,
it's an ice breaker.
And that's why Niels
Bohr said "anyone
who is not shocked by quantum
theory has not understood it."
And here's what's
amazing about it.
This is real stuff that matters
a lot for material science
and every other
discipline in engineering.
This is not just some
theoretical, very super
physics-y, probably not going
to matter to me kind of thing.
Well, this matters
a lot, because this
is how electrons behave.
And that's what,
as I said, dictates
so many of the
properties and materials
that we care about,
especially in energy,
which we'll spend some time in
this part of the class talking
about.
So I got to talk about
Schrodinger's cat.
How many of you know
about Schrodinger's cat?
Who can tell me what you
do with this poor guy?
Go ahead.
Somebody-- who said they
knew about Schrodinger's cat?
What's the experiment?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you put a
cat in the box, and--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Put a cat in a box.
AUDIENCE: And you have some sort
of radioactive element, or--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Radioactive.
AUDIENCE: --Schrodinger liked
to particle, or whatever.
And you have a Geiger counter
or something to measure it that
will break a vial of poison
if it detects the radiation
and won't if it doesn't.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And so if it radiates,
then it breaks the poison
and the cat dies.
If it doesn't radiate,
then the cat survives.
But until you observe it,
it hasn't done either,
so the cat's both alive
and dead at the same time.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: And that
was-- you see, that's exactly
right, very nice.
And the rest of that
is you say, well--
you put it so that it has a half
life something like an hour,
roughly, between when
it emits a particle.
And so then you measure
it-- and so after an hour,
there's a 50-50 chance the cat
has been killed or is alive.
But the key point is what
you said there, which
is that, until you measure it--
you see, the little
radioactive thing
is a very quantum
mechanical particle.
So until you measure it, as with
the electron, it's everywhere.
It's both emitted and
released the poison and not.
The state is quantum mechanical.
And so what Schrodinger did is
he said, well, that's absurd.
Because then if you take that
up to the macroscopic levels,
you can get these
sort of absurdities.
And that's why he
came up with this,
actually to make a point that
we don't understand this yet.
That was really the point here.
And this paradox has been--
and so, because the
point being the cat
is both dead and alive
according to quantum mechanics.
It is both.
It is a superposition
of dead and alive
until you open the box, in which
case, you collapse the wave
function because you observe it.
That would be really what
quantum mechanics tells you.
And this paradox has been
one of the central talking
points of quantum
mechanics, or examples
used to illustrate how
strange quantum mechanics is
for many decades.
And it's also led to
a lot of discussion
on how we should actually
interpret quantum mechanics.
This is called the
Copenhagen interpretation,
for those of you who are
interested in reading more,
but there are many, many others.
And I have a sheet at the end--
I'm not going to go through--
where I list like 10 or 15
different interpretations
of quantum mechanics.
How cool is that?
We really don't know
what this all means.
And that's pretty neat.
Actually, Schrodinger, I
think, he made this statement--
which I thought was funny--
about his paradox.
"I don't like it,
and I'm sorry I ever
had anything to do with it."
Because I think it got taken
out of context a lot as well,
and the whole killing
cats is not a very PC--
but he very carefully
said, pardon my--
in his paper, sorry for
being so crude about talking
about dead cats.
And the final one to look into,
but I won't talk about more,
is called the EPR paradox.
And this stands for Einstein,
Podolsky, and Rosen.
And it's a very
interesting paradox, again,
that comes out of
quantum mechanics, which
is that you can entangle
the states of two particles
together--
let's say the spin-- so
that its total is zero.
But one is one and
one is minus one.
And now as you separate
them, because they
were entangled at one
point, you can separate them
to very long distances, and
according to quantum mechanics,
they both have to
really be both.
One cannot be one and one minus
one-- the collection is zero.
But one cannot be one and one
minus one until you measure
one.
And then that one is
something, and the other one
is the other something.
And that actually leads to
some very interesting paradoxes
involving information,
because you've
gotten information about
something that's more
than the speed of light away.
Is that possible?
[INAUDIBLE]
wonderful discussions
about this kind of stuff
that I won't go into.
OK.
So now we're going to get to--
we're going to move--
those are motivations.
This is what everybody was
at the time grappling with,
is how can we
explain these things?
And what it really came
down to is that particles
can be both waves and--
everything can be both
waves and particles.
But especially when you get
down to very small masses,
the wave nature can dominate.
And that is the
case for electrons.
So for waves, they have
particle-like properties,
and for particles, they can
have wavelike properties.
And that's really
the key observation.
That's the
wave-particle duality.
And as you saw in the video,
what that means is that--
you see, a wave is a wave,
which means it can have both--
it can have interference.
As you saw, the electron,
they shoot it one at a time.
Not interfering with
another electron.
It's literally
interfering with itself.
And you can see that
you can actually
get interference patterns,
and that diffraction pattern
that you see on the plate
in the two-slit experiment
is a measurable wavelike
property of the electron.
You know what I love
so much about that is--
I don't know if you
caught it, but it's
shot out as a particle.
It's got to go through
the slits as a wave.
There's no other
way to explain it.
If you don't observe it,
it goes through as a wave.
But then in order to--
the original experiments were
done with a photographic plate
that can only be--
the track can only be
made if it's a particle.
The position of the electron
has to be a particle
to make the dot on the plate.
So it goes from particle
to wave to particle.
And that's really the
nature of quantum mechanics.
You have to be able to
describe particles as waves.
And so we start seeing
effects like this,
where you can get constructive
interference from a particle.
That's really cool.
And that's what we need
to be able to describe
to describe the quantum
world in a computer.
That's real.
That's a water
dropping to make waves.
This is actually an electron.
This is where an electron
sits on a surface.
I think that's a quantum corral.
And it's been measured
experimentally--
this is the experimental setup.
It's been measured
experimentally
for bigger things
than electrons.
You think electrons
are really tiny.
Oh, Grossman only
cares about them
for his electronics and optics,
but I care about bigger things,
like fullerenes.
Well, if you take fullerenes
and you shoot them
through two slits, you also
get a diffraction pattern.
This is real stuff.
It happens for
real bigger things.
OK, but now, could I
go through two slits?
Is that possible?
Am I quantum mechanical?
AUDIENCE: Are you
observing yourself?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I am--
I--
I don't have a good
response to that question.
But I am not observing
myself and no one else is.
Am I quantum mechanical?
Yeah.
Why don't I create diffraction
patterns wherever I go?
AUDIENCE: Too big.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Too big?
Don't read ahead!
Why am I too big?
So where does this stuff end?
Are you always a wave, no
matter how big you are?
And that's where we're
missing something.
We're missing something
really important.
The answer is, absolutely.
I am a wave, and
I'm proud of it.
My arm right now is a quantum
mechanical-- this is a wave.
This is not a particle.
If I throw this chalk--
that was fun-- that's
not a particle.
That was a wave I just threw.
It has a wave
associated with it.
It is very wavelike.
But if I throw chalk
through two slits,
will I get a
diffraction pattern?
No.
And now we're going to see why.
When is a particle like a wave?
Well, it always is--
but to varying degrees.
And that's where de Broglie
came in and generalized
what Einstein had been working
on, and others, and said, look,
everything has a wave.
Everything is both a wave
and a particle-- everything.
And he said, and
we can associate--
we can calculate a
wavelength to these things.
Here's the electron.
The wavelength of the electron
is 10 to the minus 10th meters.
Now, why is that a distance
that is making electrons really
quantum mechanical?
Or why can't I describe them
classically at that distance?
What's that distance?
AUDIENCE: Angstrom?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's an angstrom.
What happens at
the angstrom level?
Like, what's an angstrom?
What's 4 angstroms?
What's 2.447 angstroms?
AUDIENCE: Carbon.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Carbon.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE] carbon.
So that's the level of bonds.
This is it, man.
This is where--
that wavelength is
the same size as the
kind of distances
that matter to an electron,
like the distance from one
atom to another.
It's the same.
So that means--
because the wavelength
is so similar to the
world of the electron,
then that quantum effect is
going to be really important.
And the wavelength
is 100 times smaller
for a fullerene, which
means that it's maybe
less important for things
we do with fullerenes.
What do we do with
fullerenes, by the way?
Has anybody done
anything with fullerenes?
Probably not, but what
could we do with fullerenes?
No.
We're still working on it.
Make what?
AUDIENCE: Make soccer balls.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Soccer balls.
You can make pretty high
temperature superconductors--
what would have been considered
very high temperature
before high TC came on.
You can also make solar cells.
You can make electronics.
You can make all kinds of
interesting chemistries.
And most of the time, the
quantum mechanics won't matter,
but that experiment showed
that you can still measure it.
Now I have a
baseball, and here's
the wavelength of a baseball.
Can I measure that?
But it has a wavelength.
And it's just-- and
so do I. So do you.
It's just that this is
20 orders of magnitude
smaller than the diameter
of the nucleus of an atom.
That's how tiny the
wavelength is associated
with these more larger objects.
So you see, these are
very quantum mechanical,
and they do have--
they would be able to
give you the same effect,
if you could pick up--
if you can measure
distances that small.
So what we have in
classical versus quantum
is that we have to
describe in a computer
the mechanics of
waves, as opposed
to the mechanics of particles.
So what we had before--
OK, so that way,
we're going to be
able to describe the wave
and the particle behavior.
What we had before was this.
This is the mechanics
of a particle,
and you all did a lot
of simulating of this.
Did you guys do--
so did you do
molecular dynamics?
Yeah.
So you know about that.
And you did that with velocity
[INAUDIBLE],, leapfrog.
No?
How did you integrate that?
Did you pick an
integration scheme?
How did you solve that equation?
You clicked Simulate.
But there are probably--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: He showed us one
scheme where we used, I think,
the two subsequent positions
sort of got an average velocity
out of that, and--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Great.
AUDIENCE: Got it from there.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
And so they're-- right.
So here's the thing.
There are many ways to
solve this equation.
And some are more efficient to
put on a computer than others.
But none of them are
really very complicated.
We're going to have the same
thing with quantum mechanics,
it just gets a little
more complicated,
because the equation
is more complicated.
But we're going to
have the same thing.
We'll have an equation
for quantum mechanics,
and there'll be many
ways to solve it.
And we're going to learn
a little bit about them,
and then just kind of
move on and apply it.
But we'll learn a little
bit about the different ways
to solve it.
So this wave is now-- you see,
instead of being a particle,
it's now an expectation.
It's a vibration.
So what we need to
know about a wave--
oh, yeah, psi.
Psi.
When you see psi, that's like
quantum mechanics, right?
Or a fraternity?
I don't know.
But anyway, here it's
quantum mechanics.
And psi is the function.
That's it.
That's what we want to know.
That's the wave function.
That's what we're solving for
for the next so many weeks--
five weeks?
Six weeks.
We're going to be
solving for this.
This is the wave function.
This is what tells us where
those electrons are going to be
and how they're going to behave.
And so the simplest way
to write down a wave
is what's called the plane
wave, which is just a cosine--
it's a cosine plus sine,
where you have an amplitude,
and then you have this vector
k at the spatial position,
and then this frequency
times the time.
So this is the simplest
way to write a wave,
and you can find
little nice animations
on Wikipedia of what a wave
like that would look like.
That's a plane wave.
And you can see that it's
called a plane wave because you
can look at it as these
moving planes of some sort
of constant magnitude.
It's a very simple way
of describing this.
Maybe there are
more complex ways,
but this is going to be one
that we like in this class.
Now, what I was telling
you about before is
what de Broglie did,
which he said, look,
everything can be
described as a wave.
Everything can
have a wavelength.
And the wavelength
associated with anything
is going to look like this.
Did I put it here?
Yeah.
It's going to go as h
divided by the momentum--
the mass times the velocity.
So there is a
wavelength that can
be associated with anything.
That's what de Broglie said.
So he generalized what
Einstein had been working on
with light to say that
this would be something
that anything can have.
It can have a
description that can be
described by a wave function.
And that's what Einstein
already did this.
He did that part.
He said the energy
of that wave would be
proportional to its frequency.
That was part of the
photoelectric effect.
OK, so how do we describe it?
So in the last 10, 15 minutes,
we'll say, this is it.
This is where we've
been building to,
because we're going
to end with what
we need to do in this class,
which is solve an equation.
We're going to end just
with a little bit of feeling
of our F equals ma.
And our F equals ma is
the Schrodinger equation.
And I won't talk about
how it was derived.
It's actually-- it's
a wonderful story.
He was very frustrated,
because this didn't actually
agree with some of
the work that was
being done on relativistic
effects solving this equation.
And so he refused to
publish, actually,
his equation for quite a time.
And he took a
retreat to his cabin,
and apparently came back and
decided he would publish.
I love reading these stories.
Those were the days.
People really published
when they really
had something important to say.
That's cool.
And that was-- it
was just really
neat to watch the communication
between Schrodinger
and Einstein, and all these just
brilliant people of the time.
This is our equation.
This is a wave equation.
This tells us what
we need to know.
This tells us how this function
evolved in time and space.
And the key here is that this
side here has the terms--
this has the momentum
squared term, which-- you
can look at the previous page.
When you look at de
Broglie and Einstein,
h bar omega is the energy
from the frequency,
and then the
momentum, then you can
go back and see why these
things make a lot of sense.
But this is going to be--
this second derivative
here, spatial derivative,
is going to give you
the momentum squared.
So that looks kind of like
a kinetic energy term.
And that's the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy
times the wave
function gives you
something that's equal to the
time dependence of that wave
function.
The time derivative
of the wave function.
That's the Schrodinger equation.
And for this class, we will
consider that left-hand part
that has the parts that give
you the potential energy
and the kinetic energy.
That's basically how you can
think of this, of the particle.
But oh, that's the kinetic
energy of the particle,
but for a wave.
And again, you can
see why, because you
can go back and see
what this gives you,
what k this gives you.
So that's the kinetic energy,
but it's meant for a wave.
And if we assume that this
energy part doesn't depend
on time, then the
Schrodinger equation
is much easier to solve,
and we get something
that's time-independent.
And that's what we'll
do in this class,
because we can separate it into
a spatial part and a time part,
and then we can just
ignore the time part,
and we can call both
sides equal to a constant.
This is just some
very simple algebra.
And if we do that, we
can set them both equal
to some constant, let's
call it E, which is--
there's a reason for that.
And then this full
psi with the time
will depend on the spatial
part times this exponential,
and we'll just ignore
this for this class.
We're just going to
care about this part.
OK.
So let's end with-- there's
these couple of examples
that some of you have seen.
How many of you have not
seen particle in a box?
Couple people.
OK.
But if you have
seen it, you know
this is still going to be
fun, because particle in a box
is always fun.
So all particle in a box
is it's the spatial part
of the Schrodinger equation
solved for one of the simplest
systems you can
imagine, which is
that you have some quantum
mechanical particle that can
exist inside of this region.
And so in this region,
there's no potential energy.
It's just a free particle.
It's a free wave.
But then it has these
boundaries that go to infinity.
And because it has
a potential that's
infinite at the
boundaries there's
only one solution here, which
is that the function has
to be zero.
And you can convince yourself
of that just by looking at this.
If this is infinity,
psi has to be zero.
It's the only solution.
So here's what becomes really
interesting about this.
So you have-- if you look at
this equation, and you say,
well, OK, outside--
so you have two equations
you can write-- one
where there's a V,
but it's infinite,
in this case, and one where
V is zero, in which case
that part drops out, and this
is the equation you're solving.
And this has a general
solution, which looks like this.
It's a sine plus a cosine.
And from this
general solution, you
can actually write
down what E is.
That's actually very fairly
simple algebra to get to that.
But what becomes really
interesting and exciting
is when you apply the
boundary conditions.
So when you look at
what has to happen here,
you have constraints.
And those constraints lead
to something really important
that was really, really
frustrating all these people.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Quantization.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Leads to quantization.
That's it.
That's the ticket.
It's when you put boundary
conditions on the simplest
quantum particle, quantum thing
imaginable, a thing in a box,
you quantize it.
You quantize it
because, you see,
when I put these
boundary conditions on,
I'm saying that there are
only certain allowable values
for this, because of this.
So the boundary conditions
cause quantization,
and that's what gives
rise to the whole thing.
That's what gives rise to this
whole world of energy levels,
and a lot of the
things that we talked
about in the beginning that were
so challenging to understand.
So you have quantization.
You also have normalization.
We're not going to go
through this in great detail,
but that also helps you
understand what A is.
But you see there,
that has to be.
k can only be n pi over L
where n is some integer.
It can only be that because
of those boundaries.
And if you go back to the
previous page, you can see why.
So now, your energy, which
was nice and general as k,
going as k squared, can
only go as n squared
h bar squared pi squared.
So it can only go
at certain values.
It cannot be anything else.
And what you get, then,
is you get energies.
So you get energies that
have very discrete values.
And that starts to
remind me of what?
What experiment?
AUDIENCE: Photoelectric?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Photoelectric?
OK.
And what else, where you
only saw discrete values?
AUDIENCE: The spectrum?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: The spectra.
The lines.
You only saw discrete colors.
You only see discrete colors.
You guys can take a
telescope and look,
and you'll only see
discrete colors.
Now, it also gives
you something else.
It gives you psi, which
gives you these curves.
So you see, for the first
solution, n equals 1,
you get a psi that
looks like that.
But for the next
allowed value, you
get a different shape for psi.
And for the next
allowed value, you
get yet another shape for psi.
Oh, boy, is this important.
Seriously.
Check this out, OK?
Because now-- OK, so
that helps explain this.
It looks like it might.
And now we're going to do it
for V equals something that
looks more like a
harmonic potential,
and we're going to get
equations that look like this.
You see?
We get energy levels--
the quantized energy
levels that look like this,
and we get psis
that look like this.
And these are psi squareds,
which I'll tell you about in
a minute.
And that starts to
look a whole lot--
do I have it?
That starts to look a whole
lot like the hydrogen atom.
You see, look at these psis.
Look at the shapes of those.
Those have structure,
and they also have zeros.
They have places
where they go to zero.
Now, here's the critical thing.
The shape of the psi
squared is the answer.
It's where the electron
is going to be.
It is the probability of finding
the electron anywhere in space.
Psi squared is the
probability of finding
a quantum mechanical
particle anywhere in space.
It is the wave
function, and it is also
where the particle will be
with a given probability.
So the probability of finding
this particle in a harmonic
well is going to
be largest here,
and then almost zero there.
And then it's going to
go up again, further out.
And you have these
different solutions
that only happen for
certain energies.
That is exactly what's observed.
So the psi squared
is the probability
you find a particle.
Psi, we don't know what it is.
We don't know what psi is.
Does anybody know what psi is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: No,
that's psi squared.
Psi is what we solve for in
the Schrodinger equation,
and that's we're going to
solve for in this class.
Psi squared gives
us the probability
of finding that particle.
What is psi?
What does it mean?
Any guesses?
The square of it
is the probability
that you can find a
particle anywhere.
But what is psi itself?
People have struggled
with this a lot.
And you know what I think?
I think people have given up.
Because when you
read old textbooks,
old quantum textbooks--
I'm talking from
the '30s and '40s,
they talk about
that a whole lot.
And when you read new
quantum textbooks,
they don't talk
about it anymore.
Because we just
don't really know,
is the answer, what is the
physical meaning of psi.
Isn't that so cool?
We don't really have
a good grip on it.
There's a lot of
different discussions
around what it could be.
But this is the thing
that means something
we can measure directly.
It's the distribution of
where that particle is.
You see, so this is it.
This is an electron around--
this is the electron of
hydrogen. And you see,
when that electron is in--
let's take a look at this.
This is really important.
When that electron
is in this shell,
we already know
that's called the 1s.
The psi for that
first allowed energy
level, that first allowed
energy level has a shape to it,
and it's spherical,
and it looks like that.
And therefore, that is the
probability distribution
of the electron.
That's where it can be in space.
If I measure where that electron
is, where's it going to be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
if you measure it,
you're going to get back
some position for it,
and it's going to
be at that position.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
And I love that.
If I measure it, it will
be where I measure it.
Which is true.
And that's actually
the right answer.
But where will it be
according to that picture?
How can I use this picture to
tell me where it's going to be?
That is psi squared for
the electron of hydrogen
in the first level.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You guess
as to where it
will be within that boundary.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
I mean, basically, the
answer is that it tells me
where it is more or
less likely to be,
but it doesn't tell
me where it will be.
It can't tell me that.
Psi squared only tells
me a probability.
It only tells me--
it can tell me where
it can never be.
That's what these are.
Those are those zeros.
When psi squared is zero, that
electron can never be there.
But it also can tell me
with more likelihood or less
where I might find it.
So if I measure it 10 times,
well, most of the time,
I'll find it in here.
Maybe once I find
it kind of out here.
That's the nature of
quantum mechanics.
That's the relationship between
the psi that we're going
to solve for and the real deal.
Now, what you find, then,
is see, the 1s is here,
and then the 2s is here.
So these are those
allowable energy levels
for the atom, which we'll
start with that next time.
But-- wait, don't go,
we're not done yet.
So now, I've said that
the system is quantized,
which means it can only
have certain energies.
That's what the
boundary conditions do.
How does that solve my
classical atom problem?
The atom only living for 10
to the minus 12th seconds.
How does it solve that?
So basically-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: It can't radiate away
just a little bit of energy.
It can't fall in
just a little bit.
If it's going to
radiate energy, it
has to fall down
an entire level.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Exactly.
Yeah.
That's exactly right.
These electrons-- it
solves the problem
of the electron
collapsing into the core
because it says the electron
no longer can collapse
into the core, basically.
We've quantized it, so
it just can't do that.
Because you see, here's the 2s.
And then the 2p--
you see, there's
s, and there's 2s,
and then the 2p has
some shape to it.
I'm just going to put wiggles.
It's not just a sphere anymore.
It's got shape.
When you go up higher
in energy, that psi
squared has funny shapes.
But the point is that the
probability distribution
is maybe around here, and
it goes pretty much to zero.
It goes very close to zero
in between, pretty much zero,
where the chance is like
the age of the universe it
won't happen.
And so what that says
is that that electron
is just not allowed to be here.
It cannot be there physically.
It cannot be in
that part of space.
How cool is that?
I mean, how weird
is that, right?
The electrons simply cannot
exist in between the 2s
and the 1s.
They got to be at
those energies.
You cannot give it
an energy in between.
It won't take it, because the
allowed levels are quantized.
There is no in-between.
[? Buber ?] was wrong.
How many of you know--
never mind.
Nobody reads Buber.
Philosopher.
It's all in the in-between.
Never mind.
Point being that that's
really mind-blowing, I think.
The electron cannot--
now here's the question.
Well, how does it
get from 2s to 1s?
How does it get there if it's
not allowed to go in between?
OK.
These are the
interpretations-- we'll
pick up with that on Thursday.
These are the interpretations.
Look at that.
It's like a whole world.
It's incredible,
all the discussion
on how to interpret psi
and the different things.
And this is a great one.
They don't know they're
doing quantum mechanics,
but that is a double
slit kind of statement.
And finally, this is
what we talked about,
and there's some great books.
There's also many,
many places on the web
where you can read
more about this.
And on Thursday,
we're going to start
going more and more into
how we can solve this
for real materials, which
is where we're going to be
in this part of the class.